[Music]
[Applause]
whistle is the story of a young
jewish teenage activist living in a
small area of gotham city called down
river
who first gets sucked into the gotham
city underworld and then
discovers
superpowers and has to re-evaluate the
direction her life is going and whether
she can be a hero to her neighborhood
dc invited me to invent a superhero and
they knew that i was a fan of the gotham
city rogues gallery so
that was just an option do you want to
put her in gotham city and i said
absolutely
yes
the downriver neighborhood is a lot like
new york city's lower east side was in
the 1980s and the lower east side is a
traditionally jewish neighborhood with a
huge amount of jewish heritage and
culture that's still there even though
now it's populated by all different
kinds of people
well willow was growing up in gotham
city with a single mother which is how i
grew up and she's a secular jewish
person which is how i identify
um but i was really inspired not so much
by my own life but by
activist teenagers and also just
young people i know in my own life
and they are out there making a
difference publishing scenes protesting
uh trying to make
good change happen in the world and i
wanted to write a character like them
whistle superpower is a dog-related
superpower because that is the
superpower that i would like to have uh
when i imagine the fun of becoming a
superhero i thought basically the best
thing would be to have a large talking
great dane with whom to do super heroics
[Music]
manuel protano is just
he's like my favorite person that i've
never met he is in italy and we did
everything by email and pinterest and
what manuel's superpower is
is that he brings an incredible amount
of emotion and heart to gotham city and
i think people will be surprised to find
out how much they care about let's say
poison ivy and the riddler as well as
the hero characters
well poison ivy is really interesting to
me because
she is fully a villain who believes
herself to be a hero
and you know her aims you know to end
climate change to create more space for
plants on our planet right
uh all of the ecological things that she
cares about are actually really
important to many many people she's just
a terrible person and goes about it in
terrible ways she's also interesting
because she's very educated she's a phd
botanist
and she also has a tragic history so i
took all of those elements and i just
leaned into them
to create a character that my heroine a
teenager
might really admire when she first meets
poison ivy i had a lot of fun writing
the riddler
he serves as a mentor figure to my
heroine
and he has a complex new backstory that
i invented for him
i really leaned into how much i think i
might like hanging out with that guy
and
how alluring his personality might be
[Music]
you